OK, les tue l'amour, c'est vraiment
des petits détails qui peuvent t'anéantir un coup avec une meuf
en une demie seconde
*Musique*
Alors il y a les tue l'amour classiques
comme par exemple tu ramènes un soir une meuf chez toi
et tu te rends compte que tu as oublié de ranger
certains éléments.  Oh merde ...
*Musique*
Inspiration. Ou alors si tout à coup
elle a un peu faim tu peux pas lui donner à manger
n'importe quoi. Euh ...
Ah bah si tu veux j'ai du bon pâté de mouton
il périme demain donc il faut le finir
Quoi?
T'aimes pas le pâte de mouton?
*Reniflements* Tu fais pitié
Il y a un type de tue l'amour qui est assez incroyable
c'est quand tu veux être sensuel avec une meuf
et au lieu de ça sans le faire exprès
tu fais totalement l'inverse
C'est-à-dire que tu lui fais totalement mal
Hey !
Aie aie aie aie Quoi? Aie mes cheveux, mes cheveux! Ah pardon
Non mais les filles elles ont trop de cheveux
sérieux, il y en a partout
En parlant de cheveux, moi
j'ai la chance d'avoir des cheveux
euh qui lorsque je les coiffe avec un peigne
font cet effet là
la coupe de grand mère
Hey ! Tu veux avoir zéro chance avec les meufs ?
Fais comme moi
adopte la coupe de grand mère
*Bruitages*
*Bruitages*  Résultat garanti
Du coup je fais parti
de cette catégorie de mecs
qui se coiffent en mettant un bonnet sur la tête
Ou, une sorte de truc qui aplati
ça par contre la meuf
faut pas qu'elle le découvre
*chant*
Ah salut
ah non mais ça c'est parce que
c'est pour me coiffer
fin c'est parce que moi j'ai les cheveux
frisés et tout... Les gens ils pensent que
avoir un chat c'est trop mignon
et que ça va te faire gagner des points
au près d'une meuf elle qu'elle trouve ça adorable
mais on oublie souvent un ptit détail
Ah ouais ça c'était mes vacances à La Rochelle
on avait fait du deltaplane et tout
T'es trop un aventurier
*Reniflements*
Ah ça sent mauvais là *reniflement* c'est quoi ?
*Ronronnement*
*Reniflement* Ah ouais *reniflement* ouais c'est mon chat ça
*Reniflement* c'est *reniflement* ça sent un peu
ouais ça pu la merde
ouais on peut dire ça ouais. ça pu la grosse crotte
bien puante de chat. Je suis désolé
Ah moi ça ne me dérange pas
au contraire, j'aime bien
Il faut aussi que j’arrête de commander un plat épicé
quand je suis au resto avec une meuf
il y a des mecs quand ils mangent ultra épicé
euh ça leur fait rien du tout, moi quand
je mange une merguez, ça se voit direct
T'es sûr que ça va là ?
Ouais carrément ouais
je pense juste, juste que ça manque un petit peu de sel
mais euh, mais voilà
là c'est parfait
Parce que le corps d'un mec extrêmement  musclé
qui sue un peu pendant l'effort, ça peu être sexy
mais un mec qui sue comme un gros porc
parce qu'il mange une merguez c'est plutôt ridicule
Bon après il faut aussi que j’arrête de dormir avec un masque
et des boules Quies, ça c'est autre chose
Comment ça t'as pas envie de faire l'amour ?
Comme ça là ? ça t'es venu d'un coup ?
Il faut également que j’arrête de mettre
des T shirt gris
Il faut aussi que j’arrête d'acheter ce putain
de déodorant qui te fait une marque
de talc blanche sous l'aisselle
C'est qui les mecs qui ont inventé ce déo ?
Tu sors tout propre de la douche tu mets un coup
de déo et pendant 24h, t'es un gros porc avec
du talc blanc sous les aisselles.
Euh Vaness, est que tu peux me sortir
trois photocops ilico s'teuplait
tu me fais ça ASAP
Ouais j'ai changé de déo ouais
comment tu sais ? Enfin le master
tue l'amour c'est le slip que j'ai depuis que j'ai 14 ans
et que je remets seulement quand j'ai plus de caleçon propre
celui au fond de l'armoire
avec des motifs dégueulasses dessus
Tu le connais ce slip?
Enfin je veux dire personnellement ?
En tout cas ce slip c'est vraiment sympa quand tu as oublié
que tu l'as mis. J'ai envie de toi
maintenant
euh ah ouais nan, en fait je dois y aller
Merci d'être aussi nombreux sur ma page
facebook Norman fait des vidéos
j'en ai qu'une seule et elle est vraiment sympa
Et toi ?
T'as des tue l'amour ?
Aussi ?
J'ai pas de problèmes d'accord ? Je suis comme tout le monde